boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan we
are still in Boston Massachusetts we are
going to be talking about digital
medical animation we are sitting down
with the father of digital medical
animation David balinski hello Alan it's
good to see you thank you so much for
coming on the show and talking to us
absolutely David's work is so gorgeous
and educational and incredible for
expanding the awareness of Youth and
adults into our world to understand the
complexity of the inner workings of our
biological systems and you're a world
leader in this regard and I'm so so
grateful to be sitting down with you and
we'll have a lot of really great embeds
in this video to Showcase
um the gorgeous the gorgeous work that
you do
um okay we we gotta talk about how one
even gets into this because you've been
doing this how many decades now 35 years
now three and a half Decades of this and
and the pencil sketching to the actual
digital animating is so gorgeous of the
way that um that you're so able to do
that and I'm excited to talk to you
about so 35 years of this how did it how
did it start because the first gigs were
at Yale but let's talk about how you
even got into this well it goes way back
to when I was four years old and I saw
Fantasia and after seeing Fantasia I
really really wanted to be an animator
and at the time I was fortunate my dad
was a sculptor A an art historian a
professor and he taught me flipbook
animation yeah yeah and so that's when I
started making things move on paper and
as a as a teacher as a professor he was
also very aware that he had a lot to
teach me so he taught me how to draw he
was my mentor he was my muse but I was
the black sheep of the family and that
art wasn't my only interest I loved
science and the the part of Fantasia
that got me excited was the dinosaurs I
would go into my dad's studio and on
long pieces of butcher paper I would
draw dinosaurs and volcanoes and
everything that I could and so I had
that encouragement I had the the models
at his at his uh studio with his
students that I could draw from and we
moved to Europe when I was 10 and my
father became my private docent to all
of the great museums of Europe and the
cathedrals and and I was spent a lot of
time in his studio in Rome and I saw the
greatest artist of this history and I
wanted to emulate them but I wanted to
emulate them with doing science and not
just doing religious themes or other
themes that other artists will want to
do
so that background is so important that
you had that that
you can see it and be it that's such an
important part of young and when your
parents expose you to the different
stimuli and encourage you to pursue that
what was a really good encouragement was
when I was 14 years old and I had an
advanced biology course and my teacher
said see me after class oh what did I do
I had no idea what I had done and he
said bring your notes and he said see
these drawings that you put on the
margins of your notes you should be
prouder of your work than that you
should do them on a full page you could
earn a living doing that
yeah and that was like really great and
then and then when I was 15 years old my
private my our family doctor introduced
me to Frank Netter the medical
illustrator who was in MD who was the uh
the reigning medical illustrator of his
day and I decided back then when I was
15 that I wanted to follow in his
footsteps become a medical illustrator
go to medical school and then do
animation as a medical illustrator and
when I was 16 a cousin of my fathers in
Israel gave me a science fiction book by
Robert Heinlein called the Moon is a
Harsh Mistress and that book gave me the
idea that someday I would do my
animations using computers but this was
1968 so it was four years before pong
and so I had a long time to wait before
the technology caught up so I put my my
mind on becoming a medical illustrator I
got into the medical illustration
program at Ohio State and did Master's
level work in anatomy while I was there
as well I got a faculty position in
human and veterinary medicine at
Michigan state did a lot of
illustrations and applied to medical
school and got in
and two years into medical school I took
a Year's leave to finish some books I
was working on when I got a telephone
call from Yale out of the blue offering
me a position as senior medical
illustrator at the Yale School of
Medicine if I would agree to do a series
of six books for some surgeons there so
suddenly my career took a hard left and
I went from Michigan to uh to New Haven
and suddenly I was at Yale School of
Medicine I did about 4 000 pen and ink
drawings there
wow yeah Illustrated seven books and um
around 1980. this was 1980 I was invited
in December okay and uh and I started
there in January and never looked back
never told the folks at Michigan State I
wasn't coming back to medical school
yeah and because that's an opportunity
to once in a lifetime once I mean I was
28 and to be to have that position as a
medical illustrator at 28 was just too
much to say no and I did that Forefront
of The Cutting Edge there's yeah it was
The Cutting Edge of 16th century drawing
it was pen and ink no different than the
monks on parchment yeah and I wanted the
dean and my boss to get involved in
digital exactly and I said this is the
point where I think we should start
getting some computers we need to start
changing how we think about visualizing
things and the response was resolutely
no
we're we're doing things the way we've
been doing them because that's what
works and at one point the dean came
into my office and he did this which
when you put the glasses down on the
bridge of the nose is not a good sign he
said young man let me make this
perfectly clear there's no room in
cartoons in medicine
oh
and that was really stinging yeah and I
quit my job at Yale three weeks later
and I started the first digital medical
animation company in the world without
having actually learned how to use a
computer first so don't do this at home
this advice is so incredible it's it's
as though if you're just
so confident in where the trajectory of
technology is going that even when
people tell you no we're it's not
there's no space for that there's no
room for it's not going that way
you got to persevere through that oh
yeah yeah and that's what you believe in
yourself you have to as my wife says be
willing to jump off a cliff and hope you
can grow how grow wings before you go
Splat yeah and so I've learned how to
grow wings quite a few times and it's so
important that as kids leave the nests
of their parents that they grow wings
and fly successfully we're we're seeing
a lot of strange cultural norms of
coddling going on which is harming
people's confidence it is but I talk to
kids all the time and one of the things
I say in groups of kids whether it's at
the science and engineering Festival in
Washington or at other places in
classrooms I talk to them I say you know
someday you're going to have an idea
which is going to be really important to
you and you can taste it you can feel it
you can
turn it around in your head it's very
real in your imagination you know you
can do it if only you had the people who
could say to you I'm behind you yes but
you will get oftentimes any number of
excuses from people who care for you
care about you want to protect you from
yourself it's been done before and
people failed it hasn't been done for
Four so wait till someone makes sure it
works or it's too expensive or it's too
strange or too whatever and you've got
to decide are you willing to make real
what's in your head
but more important than that are you
willing to to
understand that the person who's telling
you you can't do it doesn't see it in
their head exactly and so you have to
give yourself permission to ignore the
person whose imagination fails and whose
failure of imagination is really a
failure on their part to follow along
with you and to trust you and to say
your imagination is valid where mine
isn't so I will back you up
even if I don't yet understand what you
want to do and they their imagination
may go into another place where yours
can't quite keep up or mine can't and
it's up to us to ask them questions
about it and learn and support them and
trust them
um so that's a so crucial so there's
thousands of pen and paper
illustrations that led you to mortgage
my house and buy a computer
and that was like one of like five times
I had to mortgage my house to buy
computers because back then the
computers were bare skins and stone axes
I mean they were really this was the the
digital equivalent of when I saw the
caves of let's go in uh 1962 with my
family which are no longer open to be
visited but I saw a 17 000 year old cave
paintings by people who weren't the
thuggish lumpy thick cavemen these were
thinking Homo sapiens just like you and
me but what they had going for them was
they they invented visual media they
invented the tools to make visual media
they invented the means for actually
taking a thought and giving it to
someone else to have the same thought
seventeen thousand years ago in color in
contour and and these are images that
tickle the same neurons in us as it did
in them so that was quite a huge
accomplishment that was high technology
what David's indicating right now is
what separates humans from all other
species is this ability to collectively
learn over time and pass along knowledge
through language and through ART and
that is so beautiful and that was a
spark it was a spark and then seeing uh
the uh
the drawings uh thirty thousand year old
drawings in in uh in other uh French
caves Chateau pondar where you have a
rhinoceros in four different positions
as if it were an animatic so it was the
first the first realization of motion on
a Surface where you could look at it and
say that's where I don't want to be in
front of them but it's teaching like
people who haven't even been born yet
what to be aware of yeah you know how to
approach this animal how to hunt how to
you know so all sorts of stuff was that
was going on then was stuff that I had
to deal with in doing animation because
the animation tools that I used were for
architecture
they were for building rigid geometric
shape things and lighting them and
moving a camera and I wanted to do
squishy things I wanted to do soft
things I wanted to do things that had
some transparency and so basically what
I did with computer animation was the
same thing that our Neolithic cousins
did and that's invent the vocabulary to
say what was in my head and put it on a
screen yeah so that is so important a
lot of times when we talk to Young
creative minds or even adults that are
spurring these interesting creative
thoughts in their minds there is not
always vocabulary that can explain their
imagination and so we always urge people
to come up with new words neologisms for
what the inventory of their mind is
right yeah and so what I do in my job is
I take new research whether it's on the
molecular or cellular level or a new
surgical tool or whatever and I take the
research and the findings and I turn the
words into visuals so that people who
don't even understand these new words
can learn from the visuals what's being
explained so I'm constantly developing
new visual vocabulary in order to reach
the audience and of course audiences
change I sometimes teach medical
students I sometimes teach people who go
to a museum I sometimes teach people who
are working at DARPA
and my favorite audience of course is
kids and my favorite audience is to take
what kids need to learn and give them
the excitement of that's going on inside
of me I never would have known and I
want to find out more
I love it dude I love it me too I'm so
about that so a project that I was asked
to do shortly after I left Yale after
I'd started my medical animation company
was from right around the corner it was
from the director of molecular and
cellular biology here at Harvard
and Rob blue came to me and he said I
want to do an experiment with my Harvard
students in molecular cellular biology I
want to do a film
and then he proceeded to tell me about
his his passion for for movies for
cinematography for spectacle for Grand
Vistas he said I want to make a cell
as big as a city instead of something
you peer in on and poking and and barely
see the details of I want you to go into
the cell experience the cell as a living
crowded
industrious place and take a tour and
see if that tour changes how my students
appreciate the chapter that we're
talking about to see if there's a
difference between the students that
have seen this and the students that
haven't seen this even if they've both
had the same lectures they've both had
access to the same online materials what
does a motion tour what does immersion
inside of a living cell that is created
as a grand spectacle instead of a dry
dissected object what does that look
like how does that change the perception
so we created an animation that went
with a chapter on the molecular basis of
cellular motility which you can say
three times fast cellular motility yes
how does a cell transport things inside
and so we created a an eight and a half
minute animation that was never meant to
be seen in public it was meant only to
be seen by half of one class of harder
Harvard molecular and cellular biology
students and the difference in the test
scores
was amazing now we were twiddling at the
margins of Education here we didn't
expect that the students who didn't see
our animation would average about 70
percent on the on the test which was
normal
but the students who did see our
animation averaged almost 100 percent
across the board and that distinction
was shocking to us and so what we did on
Dr Lou's request was we edited the thing
down
from eight and a half minutes to three
and a half minutes to enter in the
siggraph electronic theater to show the
world and we entered our little tiny
little animation which was competing for
uh viewing space on the electronic
theater with Sony image works and Pixar
and digital domain and all of these huge
animation companies and we had taken out
the lecture part we had taken out the
labels a friend of mine wrote the music
and we entered it more or less as a
digital poem a scientific poem to see
how people would respond at the theater
you've got about 500 Geeks sitting there
waiting to see the best animation of the
year and every single one of them had in
their pocket a DVD which had all 75
animation Snippets from the electronic
theater and our animation came up and it
got a standing ovation
and that night these Geeks started
uploading our animation onto the newly
formed YouTube this was 2006. YouTube
was about six months old and it spread
around the world like a virus and our
website went from 20 hits a week up to
hundreds of thousands of hits and it was
astonishing the response not only from
Educators in the college area where this
was originally aimed but from elementary
school students middle school students
they're teachers teachers saying I
showed this to my students it was the
first time they were excited about
biology as the first time they were
excited about science I got letters from
students in Russia and China who had
taken screen caps of our unlabeled
animation and they had labeled all of
the proteins and they said did I get
this right did I get that right people
wanting more and so that was exciting
because that led to my being invited to
give my first Ted Talk yeah and that was
an opportunity to take this into the
non-scientific realm where millions of
people could see my work and could
respond to it and we've since gotten so
many responses from people that are not
just our peers in animation but from
people in all walks of life who want
that level of observation to explain the
visual problems that they have
and so everybody in in medical animation
went from depicting proteins as
essentially colored Jelly Bean blobs to
doing what we did which we went to the
net to the protein Data Bank the
national protein Data Bank where they
have digital files of X-ray
crystallography proteins which describe
every atom in a protein and we figured
out how to take that data and engineer
it into proteins that looked like the
proteins that they wanted that we wanted
to show through the actual real shapes
where they
locked in with each other where you
could see how they functioned which was
amazing the other thing that was cool
and key
we were working on the inner life of the
cell in an environment which is
colorless
because when you're that small all of
these structures the proteins the the
structures that the proteins build
whether the little roads that that the
transport happens on or the membranes or
the organelles they're all smaller than
the wavelengths of light that depict and
Define color
so we had a free time there we had a
free hand to how do we color this and we
figured that since the inside of the
cell is warm it's slightly salty it's
wet it was very easy to say well let's
do an analogy and color these objects in
the same way that we find colors in a
coral reef
and so we borrowed the colors of a coral
reef and because there's no color there
it's not wrong and it's an aesthetic
choice and so that was a lot of fun to
figure out how to us how to assign the
Aesthetics of the colors and the shapes
in order to make it easier to remember
yeah the characters that are moving
around and so that's been a really
interesting thing and what I wanted to
do since then I get invited all over the
world to talk about this project about
other projects but the theme keeps
coming back when are you going to finish
the inner life of the cell when are we
going to see more than this three and a
half minute clip this this sampler this
teaser when can we have our students dig
into a full course in biology based on
the inner life of the cell
because what you need to do here and
what people are starting to learn in The
Sciences now is that the silos that we
put science in you've got chemistry in
this Silo you've got physics in this
Silo we've got biology in this silo
that's artificial because the chemistry
and the physics are the biology
and so what I've been endeavoring to do
for all of these 12 years since we did
the inner life of the cell is to
actually create that learning
environment to create that course for
kids in a new way to follow the new
science which is interactive yeah to
give them away not just to see what's
going on in a large environment where
they're whatever size they want to be
but the the cell is enormous it's the
size of a stadium and we had that
opportunity recently to do a course for
the Gates Foundation
and that course was based on a grant
that a a company out of uh Australia and
I won to create a couple of courses
for American community college students
who had never had science before to give
them their first taste of Science in
hopes that they would begin to think
about going Beyond Community College and
going into engineering or nursing or or
medicine or some area which would be
societally productive that they would
never have dreamed of attending before
and so we created a course on biology
and my team and I created a fly-through
model of a cell of a nerve cell a human
nerve cell we created a fly-through
model of a plant cell and a fly-through
model of a bacteria and with smart
Sparrow we created this interactive
course which allows students to fly
through these environments be presented
with problems solve the problems and
actually do things you move a protein
here you take this through there and you
see what happens when you do it right
and it's it's a fascinating area and now
with augmented real and virtual reality
it's a whole new Vista which is opening
up and I'm in the process now of trying
to work with some people to fund a the
first really complete comprehensive
course in molecular cellular biology for
middle school students that will inspire
them to go further yes and even if they
don't end up going into science
they'll end up being better citizens yes
that's correct because they'll know
the complexities yes and they'll know
that the fact that this is going inside
going on inside of me means that these
pollutants that are clouding are our
skies are going on inside of me or going
on inside my kids and that's an exciting
thing
there are so many places to take that
story that you just laid out for us the
first place that I want to take us is
that there is a
um there's a Micro World and a macro
world in the human world and it's kind
of interesting how we find ourselves so
frequently at the human level we are
there's a cosmic perspective and a
cosmic level there's a microscopic and
atomic level and we're just so
frequently stuck in the human level that
it's important to increase our awareness
to actually understand what happens
especially in the biological system that
is our body right and that being one of
the first things I want to point out the
second thing that I want to point out is
that
with that
study that you did at Harvard where half
the students scored so much higher
because they had an experiential
learning experience when you look at a
textbook or look at on a chalkboard or
whiteboard it just it doesn't give you
the same realization as if you were to
actually go into a stadium the size of a
cell a cell the size of a stadium and
you were to be able to go and walk
around the stadium to the different
components of a cell it would
tremendously change the way that you
experientially understand that aspect of
the biological system
so that is now the trajectory that we
see things moving now you have this
the the course with the Gates Foundation
that's that's going out to thousands of
students right now we're we're seeing
how people's awareness is being
impacted how they are
just like you said at least a better
more conscious more aware citizen of
understanding their bodies uh All Humans
bodies and then also in cells plant
cells there's so much more
um and then on top of that potentially
pursuing careers in stem steam also
pursuing careers that are just
able to more effectively guide
stewardship and prosperity to humanity
on this on this rock so that is so
exciting to me and now with the next
push that we're going with augmented
reality virtual reality these mixed
realities it's only going to become more
and more regular for us to see children
that gain the ability to experientially
learn and just pop up a cell right here
in the middle of the classroom and start
seeing the labels and pulling things
apart and experientially going through
it and that is going to just change the
way that we forever understand again the
collective learnings going from the cave
paintings to what we did the last couple
thousand years to now being able to
digitally understand the medical
infrastructures of our bodies that's
exciting stuff I mean it's so exciting
because when I first started this
I had such a long time to wait from when
I imagined doing this in visual in in
digital Visual and actually being able
to do it but but the the the the the
tools that I had were so primitive I
mean my first time that I got digital
video RAM so that I could actually have
something move a little bit on my video
on my on my computer screen without
having to render each frame first that
was a thousand dollars for a megabyte
and just the other day I saw that there
is a an SD card an SD card this big that
has a terabyte now a terabyte so you're
thinking a trillion dollars
for that thousand dollars a megabyte Ram
that you can get for 40. yeah yeah
incredible and it's just the
exponentials are enabling this to happen
and it's so it's so cool how now with
having to pay thousands of dollars for
the first computers for doing these
digital medical illustrations to now
being able to democratize not only the
Technologies for people to be able to
learn
these immersive experience through but
also to create them yes themselves
absolutely on both on both cases I mean
my first computer was send me back a
couple hundred thousand dollars and was
obsolete the moment I bought it
and I had to teach myself Unix I had to
teach myself assisted Administration I
had to teach myself about operating all
the electronics and Signal processing
and finally get it onto tape I mean in
order to get something moving I had to
take my entire system down in
Connecticut put it in my car drive down
to New York City where a company had a
refrigerator size Sony tape machine with
two inch wide tape on these huge reels
that could actually
click off one frame at a time so I could
I'd have to put my whole system down I
had stacks of of memory discs that had
one image each oh my gosh I'd have to
put an image that I made into the buffer
bring it up on the screen
I could get one frame clicked onto the
tape recorder I have to do that all over
again hundreds and hundreds of frames in
order to get a few seconds of animation
and it took a huge amount of effort and
now you can do a million times more on
your phone yes yes which is great the
democratization of it is fabulous and
David it's so important that you teach
us about the hard work that got us to
this point because to we too quickly are
immersed in what exists now
technologically that we forget about the
gratitude that we need to express to the
ancestral lineage of technology that got
us to where we are today what that did
for me though is it gave me a
perspective that I try to impart to
students and one of the things that I
say that once you've decided
to do what is in your dream once you've
decided to say to your mentor
either helped me
or gracefully get out of my way that's
right once you get to that point you are
then going to have the hardest work
you've ever done in your life and it's
going to be harder than you can imagine
now the work to get to where you can
easily imagine it being finished to get
there and make it finished is way harder
than you can imagine and I had no idea
how hard it was going to be when I left
my cushy job at Yale to start becoming a
medical animator it literally took me
five years to earn a penny and I spent
five years drawing books by hand at
night while I was trying to be an
animator during the day in order to make
it work but it can be worth it I want
people to hear this and think some
people get scared some people are
worried that art entrepreneurs and
artists take years and years to make
money I don't know if I can do that
the the sheer importance of stories like
this is to break is one of the most
crucial Parts is to be able to break
through these walls of adversity that
get put through us there are these walls
that we're saying David you're not going
to make money for one year for two years
for three years don't do it you have to
make money you have to find other means
of survival
etc etc the the I think it's so so
important to know how to live poor to
basically eat for five years so
that you can do what you love in life
for the next 40 50 years yeah it's worth
the sacrifice in the short term to be
Penny paycheck to paycheck to paycheck
to paycheck barely getting by
just so that you can for the next
several decades pursue what you love
every single day and you're really
pursuing what you love every day for
those five years but it's just not as
financially stable well but that's true
but I would be totally remiss and I
would be uh uh not telling the truth if
I didn't say that I have a wonderful
woman my wife Patty who supported this
shout out and and she was she's an
amazing uh she's a psychotherapist and
she's she's yell trained and she is just
amazing and she has she took a deep
breath and said well you know if you're
in in for a penny I'm in for a pound
that's right and that's amazing that's
right and and it's also this is coming
this is a very interesting time that you
bring this up because
we are s we're just so
engulfed and entrenched in our own egos
so often now that we don't even humbly
Express how we stand on the shoulders of
giants much anymore you humbly just
expressed your wife's assistance and and
help and does and belief in you and
trust in you and I've had that same from
my family as well and my friends that
have helped me along the way and we
stand on the shoulders of giants that
have built up the technologies that
we're privileged to have today that made
this happen so I think it's so important
the the whole the whole era of the
self-made and and having to prop up our
own egos it's also really important to
stay humble and say that I've had so
much help in my life well I have the
artists that have worked with me my
teams uh the people who decided that
they would risk
what they didn't understand to put what
I wanted to put on screen on screen and
they learned along with me and they
taught me a lot and and the the the
biggest privilege for me is to say to
these people these are my sketches these
are my ideas uh I haven't animated in a
few years although I did for many years
but I want you to surprise me
I don't want you to just slavishly
follow what I'm asking you to do I want
you to use your imagination your
creativity and you surprise me with
something I couldn't have thought of and
they always do yeah and it's great
I love how you explained to us that it
is now going past even uh of just the
inner life of a cell now we're going
into neurons into plant cells bacterial
cells we're going into the immersive
environments of flying through them
actually you were teaching me about
Sterling I think this is important to
explain
from a technical perspective it's it
goes for you from drawing sketching it
out on drawing pen and paper pencil
paper two then beginning the initial
ideas on on the digital infrastructures
that you have but then there's this
whole process of of coloring and shading
and to teach us about this okay well
it's it's it's really a it's it's a
developmental process conservative so if
I have a sketch of a scene I do it in
pencil I work with the model makers to
create a digital object that looks very
much like my drawing and then we imbue
materials to it we add extra detail by
creating texture maps that we apply we
project these colored texture detailed
maps onto our object we light the scene
we create backgrounds we create
choreography so that the different
models that we make are interacting with
one another and then we create camera
motion and to give the viewer a tour and
then we create
uh a rough animation of what's going on
so we start out with sketches and the
storyboards that we put to in time to
the voiceover and so we basically have
like a moving drawn cartoon and as we
build models we replace the drawings
with the models as we make the models
more sophisticated add color add texture
add detail we replace those so this film
starts out as sort of a flickery pencil
drawn tour through our story and it gets
more built out more sophisticated and
finally at the very end we add sound
effects we add music we add some special
effects we add the finishing touches
that make it what you would see as as a
final end user and so it's a totally
iterative
task and a totally iterative path and at
a certain point of course you have to
stop because we're limited by things
like budget and so schedule and
available talent and and those things
have to be paid attention to because
those are real world constraints
the thing that I'm working on right now
is is the ability to get larger uh
sponsors sort of like the meta cheese
sponsored Michelangelo and these these
princes would sponsor the work of great
artists yeah the great artists could
concentrate on doing what they do yes
and I think that model is useful because
it's not always possible to do great
work when you're looking for a return on
investment you need to do great work for
the great work for what it will imbue on
its users as opposed to the dollar uh
bottom line yeah we're so far we're so
far away from right now being able to
help artists become their fullest in our
world because markets the capital
markets don't reward them to focus on
what they love doing because then they
can't have an adequate amount of time
and resource allocation themselves if
you if you really want to get
exceptional at something you got to put
in the thousands of hours into it but if
no one is is paying for what you're
doing in this thousands of hours are
becoming exceptional at something then
are we going to say it's completely
useless because the markets don't value
it but that's not the case now I mean
there are many artists who go on forums
to show their work they get criticism
they got critique they get they get
praised they get guidance and there are
many people who put those thousands of
hours in on their own regardless of what
other work they're doing to put food on
the table the the technology is so
inexpensive and so powerful and the
learning tools that you can take from
offline to learn how to do what you want
to do are so powerful that you can have
people who literally can sponsor
themselves to learn the work but to put
a larger work together still requires
teamwork it still requires a lot of
equipment it still requires resources
but the skill sets that are available
are phenomenal right now there's more
artists working now really really
skilled artists working now than at any
time in the history I mean if you look
at the if you sit down and look at the
at the post credit
a list of people who work on one of
these Marvel Comics movies or one of
these DC Comics movies you'll see 400
500 600 people
who are in the background making all
these effects built World building on
these movies where you can't tell the
difference between what's real and
what's not and you look at the the
series that are being done by Netflix
and by Amazon the phenomenal worlds that
are being created where you literally
don't know that that isn't there that
they didn't set a camera up in that
place because you can't tell the
difference and the the Artistry that's
involved is unsung but it's there and
it's true and these people are being
compensated for their work right you're
right that's that's good that you
brought us to this but computer Graphics
are interestingly enough
indistinguishable nowadays in many ways
from reality right and we're only
blurring that line more and more as we
go into the future which is the proof of
Arthur Clark's Law which is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic yep and I'm
happy I'm happy you brought that up it
just it seems as though my
my previous statement was was geared
towards uh more of a potential Market
correcting solution to enable more
artists that are not at the level of
computer generated imagery at Netflix's
and Amazons in the world as though we
know so many artists that are working
without residencies without these as you
said previously princes that were able
to help fund potentially a thousand
dollars a month or whatever there are
potentials like Universal basic income
or there are other potentials like these
sort of crowds crowdfunding platforms
like patreon and whatnot that enable
artists to to slowly aim to build
themselves up but one major principle
that is lacking and we've mentioned this
on the show before is this notion of oh
I've made Thirty forty thousand dollars
I'm gonna go buy a Tesla what would
happen if you took the Forty thousand
dollars and gave one thousand dollars to
40 different artists what would that do
to civilization If instead of propping
up an ego that we went and potentially
propped up
other people's success in life and we
explored what a model system like that
would look like this is very difficult
to make a complete transition over into
something like that but I feel as though
we're moving in that direction more my
father experienced that in the 1930s he
was a WPA artist for The Works projects
Administration and he did Art paid for
by the government because the government
decreed that it is important for a
society even coming out of a depression
to have functioning artists and so the
government set resources aside to give
artists good work to do and you can
still see their work in Old Post Offices
and other places because and on Bridges
and they gave sculptors and Painters and
mural makers and all of these artists
work to do and it was real work and it
was good work and it was quality work
and we would not do poorly to replicate
something like that today
yeah but the other thing about that is
is that these movies that we're seeing
these commercials that we see are doing
an incredible job in training everybody
in the population to be visually
literate yeah to expect good quality to
expect to be taught to expect there to
be a lasting value to what they're
seeing as opposed to eye candy and so
the the uh the audience and the market
for the stuff that I do is largely
informed by the stuff that they see in
the see in the commercial world and they
say well I'd like to apply that to what
my visual problem is and so it's it's a
it's a virtual Circle
virtuous circle yeah yeah
as you talk brought back up the visual
aspect to things it also reminded me
about something I wanted to mention
earlier that when you're looking at a
textbook or chalkboard whiteboard that
it is sometimes there's a just a
labeling of certain areas and the sort
of memorization that is just kind of
what we've been teaching and the shift
over into this visual understanding the
the that we're taking into these
experiences these three-dimensional
experiences that then we can go and
position ourselves within the
environments and understand how they
work that that sort of learning I wonder
how if we could measure
let's say on a full like what was done
at Harvard just this full uh awareness
test about the biological workings of
this of of a system or even maybe a
civilizational uh an understanding of
how civilization evolved over time
that could be a sort of fundamental base
camp that children need to get to before
spurring off into whatever field they're
interested in yeah sure well this has
been studied the Wharton School years
and years ago created a landmark study
where they studied retention of material
uh given three different ways my lecture
my reading and my visuals and by far the
visuals were more highly retained for a
longer time at a greater level of detail
than any of the three modalities and so
as you create visuals that are more
involving more immersive more
personalized where you can actually
interact and what happens if I push this
what happens if I do this that retention
becomes more and more personalized and
as anybody knows when you have a
personal response to a personal
experience you will remember that much
more than if it's second or third hand
yeah so and I'm glad that you brought up
that the study the first-hand learning
that
and we see this in new schools that are
being built around around the world
where the project-based learning
experiential learning
um your daughter spending time at with
her with meow wolf right this the fact
that you're going into experiential
environments to go and learn and play is
so much now the new modality of
experience and learning than is to go
and and flip through a book and try and
yeah yeah and there's nothing wrong with
books I just saw something online the
other day there was this book that you
open up and
whatever was on the pages comes up on
your 3D glasses as a three-dimensional
environment that you look in and zoom in
and it's just astonishing what can be
done now and it's exciting these are
really exciting times for education I
think we're not anywhere near being the
Golden Age yet we're still at the Silver
age we are still at where the the Wright
brothers have sold their first airplane
commercially and we have not come
anywhere close to what we've got today
and it's going to be really exciting
next few years and of course you've
mentioned exponential growth exponential
growth means that what would take a
hundred years in a previous generation
can now be looked forward to for
yourself or at least your kids and so
these things are going to be coming Fast
and Furious and the question is how do
we tame them how do we make sure that
people get out of them what they really
need and how can we make sure that this
experience that's a wonderful learning
experience can be on the devices of 400
million kids instead of 10 yes yes
exactly the democratization getting it
out there's I like how you put it into
perspective of of
look an analogy to the Wright brothers I
like that a lot it is only in the
nascent stages
um and it's exciting to think about what
it'll be like for the kids in the next
couple decades to be able to
just just
drastically go from the age of 10 and
knowing what they know to the age of 20
and and again through those first two
decades of life being able to
immersively experience immerse
themselves into different learning
environments about the Sciences about
math and history and language Etc
because that is going to breed just
hyper knowledgeable I think next
generation of of Youth and I think it's
really important for people like me and
I've talked about this before want to
make sure we know
stay humble because in 25 years when us
that are in our mid-20s are 50 it's
going to be really important for us to
look at the kids that are born today and
be humble and say hey what do you know
that we don't know teach us yeah teach
us about what you know because a lot of
times the the transgenerational wisdoms
have issues where youth don't want to
learn from old old don't want to learn
from Young because this is some sort of
barriers and toughness to learn but
figuring out the most smooth way to do
that is so so important and it's also
important to note that in any new art
the art itself needs to develop quite
far along before the Mozart or Einstein
of that art
finds traction yeah yeah and so for for
people in my generation the uh it was a
mystery of how rap music could find
validity on any level uh or even become
interesting to listen to because it was
so discordant from what we knew and the
structures that we knew and the the way
stories were told but then Along Comes
Hamilton and that's the of course of
course it couldn't be done any other way
but until you get the master who says
how can we put this inside of a human
framework where it opens up fast
expanses that people couldn't have seen
before this you you only see it as a
tool and sometimes as an irritant
sometimes as as a passing fancy but not
something that you can build on and
everything needs its genius to get to
that point
such an interesting perspective on it
that it'll take time for lots of humans
to play with these new technologies
until we find the Geniuses that emerge
from them oh that's so cool that's so
good to mention now okay a couple quick
thoughts on the way out because there's
you know we just talked about
so much coolness to to digital medical
illustrating and animating and it's it
so beautiful to be able to see the the
embeds in this in this video about what
you've actually done over the last 35
years and where things are going thank
goodness to all this hard work from the
teams again and all the nuance and
detail that you described throughout
that actually got us here and all the
people that believed and trusted so okay
couple questions on the way out
what would you say is a core guiding
principle of your life
trust my imagination
um don't take no for an answer
um
finding people I can trust
with my emotions with my dreams with my
mistakes
and realizing that if I fail when I fail
I've learned enough to found to to put
the foundations together for another
attempt that's better and I'll fail
better next time
and occasionally you have something that
changes everything so the inner life of
the cell for instance was a difficult
project to create it was a project where
the uh the intention wasn't known at the
beginning in terms of what it would
produce how it would look how it would
be received and again as I say it was
never meant to be seen by anybody other
than a small group of students and by
now it's been seen by tens of millions
of people recently I Googled the inner
life of the cell so guess how many hits
I got
Euro tens of millions isn't it 279
million hits
now it varies some days it's only 240
million hits some days it's 480 million
hits but it's way more than any other
topic of science that I can Google and
it's astonishing that 12 years on since
we created it it still has this
resonance even though nothing new in
that area has really been made yet but
it's there the awareness is there and
it's ripe to to harvest which is what I
expect to do over the next few years
this is why it's such an honor to be
able to sit down with David because
David is that he is that that
foundational pillar that we're building
up on the digital medical illustrations
and animations you are that you are that
for us for all of us and that's why this
is such such an honor and oh my gosh
I'm so excited about the way that
awareness is going to be able to be
expanded for the next Generations of
humans thanks to these Technologies and
designs that you're helping push along
okay uh next question is
um
it wouldn't be simulation if we didn't
ask you do you think this
reality is a simulation no okay why do
you think this is a base reality
even if you ascribe to the Multiverse
where you split the universe every time
a decision is made
you've got
literally trillions of conscious
entities
of course if you ascribe to the current
feeling in some areas of physics where
Consciousness is a foundational
component of matter
and that as matter becomes accrets to be
more complex the Consciousness that
attains is that much more complex so a
bacterium has its Consciousness we have
ours the sun probably has its Pan
psychism and the issue of every choice
splitting the universe
is it can't be upheld there's not enough
matter
at least the way I see it
to be a simulation to be a simulation
why would you do that what's the point
you do that you yourself do that when
when we did the inner life of the cell
the the biggest
problem that we had in depicting
cellular life on that level of detail
was that cells are so efficiently made
so compact so full of molecules that
have function
that if you were to actually find a
camera small enough to fit in a cell and
start shooting you would be seeing
essentially a snowstorm at midnight with
your high beams on there would be so
much material there would be nothing to
see totally and so what we did we had to
dissect out 85 percent of the cell
in order to have room between our
virtual lens and a horizon so that we
could tell a visual story yeah and so
the the the the uh the story that we
told wasn't as realistic as people think
it was incredibly stylized it was a
cartoon that my Dean so disparaged it
was literally a an abstract imagining of
what the real thing is at such a low
level of fidelity that it becomes more
and more astonishing to me now 12 years
later with just what's been found out
about cellular Anatomy that I feel that
I'm in a privileged position now
to start this late doing the inner life
of the cell for kids because had I
started five years ago I would have
missed out missed out on so much that's
been found out in the intervening years
that the kids will need to know that
we'll need we'll need to be able to
explore and so I'm not I'm not deferring
on your question of whether this is a
simulation I'm just saying that there
isn't a point
that I see to this being a simulation
because there's so much stuff that is so
real the the harder we look the the more
detail we dig into the more we find
that's there and uh I don't I don't care
how good a simulator you are that's
that's a pretty tall order to be able to
make an infinite number of discoveries
possible and so I think that it has to
be real and I'll be happy to just say
it's real and if anyone wants to think
it's a simulation good luck we're
working on proving it David working on
improving it there's a lot of
mathematicians that say this is not a
simulation oh of course there are a lot
that say that it very well likely may be
in I'll be happy to do what I do inside
a really cool simulator totally that's
and that may be what you're doing
leveling up right now so you actually
brought this into perspective which is
interesting that with the the with the
cell as you go and you dive in and you
show people what the inner workings are
that if you didn't remove that 85
percent of the that'd be like if we had
to see all of the oxygen and nitrogen
right now in the air in front of our
eyes it'd be you couldn't see it'd be
that snowstorm that you're describing so
I thought I thought that was very
interesting so all right and then the
last question is
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world
my family
tell us why tell us why how's why
because it's it's it's what's real to me
you know all of this other stuff my work
is is is important it has value in and
of itself I put a roof over my head I
you know go on occasional trips but it's
it gives me a perspective that the the
stuff that is always changing and
slipping through your fingers is the
people that you know the people you
trust the people you raise the people
you advise so family could be an
extended family of of the people that I
have relationships with but that's the
most important thing everything else is
is fluff
truly
what about the millions of kids and
adults that are watching in your life to
sell like how is that's not fluff that's
extremely important of course it is but
those people who are watching have
families
and that's that should be what's
important the rest is stuff you can
learn you you layer that onside on on
top of the rest of your life okay
fair fair and that's okay fair
David honor such an honor thank you Alan
it's always a pleasure I'm so looking
forward to the future with you yeah
thank you thank you wish me luck I wish
you a luck we do we do we wish you so
much luck and
um and all the hard-working people that
you work with yeah yeah so much so so
such important awareness expansions that
are going on in our world thanks to
illustrators and animators especially in
the digital medical field is so so
interesting
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
greatly appreciate it give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you also uh go and check
out some of the links below to David's
work go and follow up and check that out
and get inspired go and build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone maybe become the next
illustrators and animators of our future
be those next generational Geniuses that
we so desperately need much love and we
will see you soon
peace bye
well that was fun yay that's how we do
yeah that's cool great that's how we do
[Music]